this already feels more like a video
game adaptation of a movie than the
movie itself it was not my intention to
talk about the Jurassic world trailer I
watched it thinking I maybe I'd send out
one snarky tweet about the thing but
then I watched it and I got really
annoyed to the point that I've got more
thoughts than can be put into a tweet so
before I talk about this trailer let me
talk about the mindset I'm coming at
this from the first Jurassic world
what's fine I enjoyed it for what it was
I'm mad when I did it I was still doing
sort of one sentence reviews on Twitter
I don't do those so much anymore but at
the time I basically said I went in this
expecting dumb fun and I got it but I
wasn't expecting it to be this dumb and
that's kind of my thought on Jurassic
world it's fun it's enjoyable for what
it is but boy is it stupid and that that
wouldn't be such a problem except that
the franchise had been smarter than this
was so it felt like a downgrade if I was
coming in like cold for the first time
and you know this was a brand new
franchise it was just going this is the
kind of dumb where I might have rolled
with it better but anyway that's my
thoughts on the previous one again
nothing against and I know some people
really love the heck out of it awesome
happy you did as far as this trailer I
was already annoyed with it for a couple
of weeks so if you listen to my podcast
feed you know I've been irritated this
thing for a couple of weeks because
every week they were releasing another
tiny ass clip burst it was the six
seconds of Chris Pratt petting the tiny
Raptor and then it was 15 seconds of
them running away from the volcano and I
I get I got annoyed a because I hate
this style of marketing and be because
every time it happened they blew up my
Twitter feed like everyone had reactions
and thoughts and breakdowns and hot
takes on six seconds of footage look
people I understand and I do not
criticize the validity of putting out
your thoughts or reactions to a trailer
I'd be a massive screaming hypocrite if
I did but six seconds at that point you
know what you do it you're doing
universals marketing for them and you're
not even getting paid for it so I will
admit I came into this kind of with a
bias against it but it managed
even undercut my low expectations of
expecting not to be impressed by this
trailer in the first place I'm not even
sure where to start well first up I
think it's probably a mistake to bring
Chris Pratt back he didn't work for me
last time as a character and which was
it took me what a while to figure out
why given that his character's
personality in Jurassic world was not
that different from his personality
star-lord I really like him as star-lord
I think the main key difference is I
understand why star-lord behaves that
way in his so immature this guy a
theoretically grown-ass male who's been
living in the real world he just comes
off as irritating and a little bit of a
douche and Bryce Dallas Haller Howard
was a walking cliche but that's me
ripping on the old one so immediately
seeing those characters brought back to
the forefront I'm like that doesn't bode
well and then it's like well we got to
get him off the island cuz there's a
volcano
alright first of all wait what volcano
really okay this means one of two things
either there was always a volcano on the
island that the park was on in which
case what is wrong with you how stupid
are you to make that thing there
something that is that hard to recreate
and I understand people live next to
volcanoes but like this is a massive
multi-million dollar facility you
couldn't find an island that didn't have
them okay you know so either it's dumb
for that reason or secondary to that if
this is one of the other islands that
happens to have dinosaurs on it which is
doubtful by the way cuz then blue
wouldn't be there but let's suppose for
a second is then that's still stupid
because of what feeds in immediately
after because we have this sort of it
looks like a Senate hearing sort of
thing as somebody has you know do we
afford these creatures the same real
rights and considerations that we afford
any species even if the answer is yes
I'm pretty sure that we are not in the
habit of going in and evacuating the
native species of an island because of a
volcano
especially if as I said if this is a
secondary Dairy Island and not the
primary one they wouldn't be the on that
island only anyway so they're not in
danger of going extinct based off that
one volcano so aside from the volcano be
really
and very much cliche it just picking at
it makes it feel even dumber even
stupider I feel like this thing is at
this point is just wallowing and dumb
and it's not without merit look I feel
like the thing was sort of trundling
along and then it went
look we got a Tyrannosaurus roaring in
front of an exploding volcano isn't that
awesome and you know what flat-out
honesty yes it is that was very awesome
you know what would be even more awesome
if it was in a movie that wasn't
otherwise really really really dumb and
that's sort of my usual thing that I go
to when people tell me but isn't that
awesome and it's in something that
otherwise doesn't hold up that's a big
part of why I bowed out of transformers
after the first one I know what ton of
people thought well the first one was
pretty good it's like no it wasn't like
what I saw was cool but it was
surrounded by dom man night apparently
bowed out before it got even worse the
other thing that's really aggravating
about this is there was a lot of stuff
set up and hinted at in Jurassic world
that again what's pretty dumb but
pointed to new possible directions that
would be if not smarter at least
different and more interesting like the
whole thing with dr. woo the implication
that engine has something else going on
has other plans for these dinosaurs or
with the technology that was used to
create them that is interesting I'm
curious about that because again if
nothing else even if it's dumb it's a
different kind of dumb then this one
which appear in which apparently seems
like it's trying to compete with
Jurassic Park 3 for most contrived
reason to put people we already know
back on the same freakin island again
here we do not have a hint of anything
that was very blatantly laid out with
stuff in Jurassic world now if I'm to
give this thing the benefit of the doubt
I don't think it's actually this
intelligent but look let's be fair it is
possible that everything they've shown
us is very early in the film and all the
stuff of them going back to the island
is more but first act and then they're
holding stuff from later on and that's
where they'll pay off the things like
you know dr. woo and his research in
engine and you know really go more
inventive with it cuz that that's the
thing I don't I don't mind dumb I do
mind dumb and predictable and that was
kind of where things fell down for me a
little bit with Jurassic world it didn't
have a lot of surprises up its sleeve it
had a couple of good nostalgia moments
up its sleeve but didn't have a lot of
surprises
gotta be dumb ie I would like it to not
feel like it's dumb I've seen some
version of even if you do it on a
technical level that is higher than
anything else and I'm not acting like
Jurassic Park is some sacred cow of a
franchise look the original Jurassic
Park is a little bit more than an
elevated b-movie but it wasn't only
elevated in terms of the technology used
to create the monsters it was elevated
in terms of the tone in the quality of
the characters the depth of them the
intelligence of the writing again it's
not like I've I do I love Jurassic Park
a lot but a lot of ways it's not a
masterpiece but it just everything was
approached with here's this b-movie
premise and we're bringing everything up
a notch where's Jurassic world when
here's this b-movie premise we're
improving the effects
you're gonna improve anything else while
you're there don't were proving the
effects that's it same b-movie just
better effects and don't care I was so
annoyed with this thing so early on you
couldn't even dangle Jeff Goldblum in
front of me and get me to care about
this and I love me some Jeff Goldblum
and yeah that was that was a bit venti
but out I don't know why this is not a
franchise I care about it wasn't movie I
was planning on see even before the
trailer came out so I don't know why it
got me so worked up but I did and I kind
of had to vent it out and again if you
like dress world awesome if you're
excited by this trailer awesome that is
great I'm not saying you shouldn't be
I'm envious that you can be excited for
this or that you would like the last one
I wish I could have but I didn't so this
is me just ranting about why that is the
case I'm assuming some people agree with
me a lot of people probably don't but
you know what
in any case whatever your thoughts are
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it don't forget to like
subscribe check me out on Twitter at
Council of geese give a listen to the
Council of geeks podcast that is
available on Apple podcast and stitcher
radio I'm also one half of the punch
like a girl podcast which is a
presentation of the fire and water
podcast network Fire and Water podcast
comm links for all this stuff is down in
the description and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]